our next speaker
likes to in her free time she trains
acrobatics so i want to know is she
being trained in acrobatics or she
training other acrobats everyone please
welcome jordan
thank you so much jared um to answer
your question prior to a knee injury
that i am currently dealing with it was
both
now it's nothing
um
but back to the subject so i will be
sharing with you guys today a model that
we built to classify medical conditions
using natural language processing
natural language processing abbreviated
nlp
is basically when we
use ai to understand a human language
instead of ones and zeros right so
english spanish matter and it doesn't
matter
um
this type of ai is really good on
unstructured data like text or audio and
the techniques that can be used to
accomplish this type of analysis range
from you know rules based entity
extraction entity recognition to
statistical modeling to machine learning
and deep learning
so
in particular when we when it comes to
medical data nlp has a really important
role for a number of reasons so first of
all if you're more than a few years old
probably
some of your medical records were
originated on paper
and we need to be able to pull the text
off that paper and understand it if
we're going to be able to analyze it
even in terms of recent records
sometimes some hospitals or healthcare
providers are working with legacy
systems maybe they print out a form and
you have to fill it out by hand because
they don't have enough computers um and
then even if we have the most up-to-date
perfect technology
uh
when we talk about you know the clinical
progression of an illness or
sort of abstract symptoms that we're
feeling that we don't have a diagnosis
yet
we're going to need to use descriptive
language and kind of descriptive
summaries so nlp has a really important
role in analyzing medical data
but when we talk about medical language
so of course especially if i'm a patient
describing my own symptoms probably i'll
use really simple words like my ankle
hurts or my ankle is swollen
um
but
a doctor prescribing a diagnosis or you
know a patient repeating a diagnosis
that they have received is going to
involve you know words like
osteoarthritis or these more technical
specific medical terminology which come
from greek and latin roots they have
prefixes and suffixes and honestly the
syntax around the way we put those roots
together is a little different than the
way it would be in english
so any nlp modeling that we use to
handle medical language is going to need
to be able to accommodate both regular
simple english and these more technical
greek and latin based medical terms
so if we look at the client case that we
built this model for
there actually were many stuff but we're
going to focus on these three so um we
needed to work with records as far back
as the 1950s so some of them were
definitely paper
we needed to be able to scan records off
of paper
uh
extract the data and save it as text we
used to do that we used ocr or optical
character recognition you've probably
seen these eights before um
it's just machine learning that
specializes in recognizing characters
like numbers letters punctuation in
two-dimensional images and saving them
as the corresponding
ones and zeros for the computer to
understand what character they are
once we have this text saved our
classification task which is what i'll
focus on was to
sort the conditions into
medically relevant categories for
processing downstream in their system
so therein lies the first challenge
which is that we had over a hundred
medical categories that we needed to be
able to sort cases into um so you know
we know that your joints are orthopedic
injuries or conditions but each joint
has its own specialist so you have a
wrist specialist an elbow specialist a
shoulder specialist etc um and then you
get into the internal medicine like the
body systems you probably remember those
from eighth grade biology you have your
digestive system your respiratory system
your endocrine system
um and extra points if you can if you
know what the endocrine system does
um so we had a lot of different uh a lot
of different categories that we needed
to be able to sort these
strings of text into
a couple other challenges we were facing
is that we actually did receive training
data from the client which was great
that doesn't always happen
uh but
some of the data that we received had
contradictory labeling so for example a
single condition would be labeled as two
different categories throughout the
training set
um and
there were also some categories that we
needed to be able to classify conditions
into that we didn't have any examples of
in the training set
so the training data was obviously
better than nothing but it wasn't ideal
we still had some problems there and
then
because of the nature of
some of the scans that we were working
with the ocr was producing some errors
with you know poor scans or perhaps
great scans but poor handwriting um
you can see some examples here so
actually for to address that the first
thing we did is make sure that we had a
spell check layer that we could feed the
text through before we even got to any
classification to
correct for those
small ocr errors
so for some examples we can see so
diabetes affects the endocrine system
now you know
carpal tunnel is a risk condition so
that goes to orthopedics wrist
pancreatic cancer is cancer so it's
going to be oncology but the pancreas is
part of the digestive system
so it's oncology digestive system
on the other side we have pancreatitis
your pancreas is still your digestive
system but it has nothing to do with
cancer so you can see how we have some
really thin lines between the categories
um
and then so bullet wound in left hip
there's a category for like wounds and
trauma um super fun category
so the original model that we
that we tried out we had the input text
we put it through the spell check layer
like i mentioned then we extracted some
features we extracted keywords specific
you know names of illnesses organs
uh body parts
and then we also extracted trigrams so
in this case trigrams is referring to
groups of three characters so for the
word trigrams it would be
t-r-i-r-i-g-i-g-r
um
and that helped us a lot with the like
prefixes suffixes greek and latin roots
and the fact that
a lot of uh the
medical like technical medical terms
were very commonly misspelled which i
really can't blame anyone for because i
can't spell any of those words either
um once we had these features extracted
we threw them into a multi-layer
perceptron which is a simple neural
network and it's that out of
classification for us
so
this worked okay
um we had
a really high a really wide range in
accuracy from retrain to retrain um even
though we had over 20 000 uh
training cases rows of training data
uh
we also had over a hundred categories so
if you think about it's really not that
many examples per category and the
distribution of cases across category
was really uh varied
uh based on just what had come in um in
the medical system that they were
pulling the data from
uh so it was a pretty unstable model and
it really struggled with cases that
crossed categories so
uh bullet wound in shoulder
if you think about it statistically uh
both in the training set and
uh it was reflective of so is a us-based
client um so in the u.s
there are
many more orthopedic shoulder injuries
than
bullet wounds and trauma wounds in
shoulders
um
so you know statistically speaking
the model has learned that if the word
shoulder is mentioned it's more likely
that it'll be an orthopedic shoulder
classification
than a bullet wound classification and
playing around with that in terms of
weighting the data set
was
causing uh
a lot of
issues with uh over correction and it
really didn't seem to be the solution
um
so you know we were looking at this and
trying to figure out how we could
improve this underperforming model and i
think a lot of times in our field the
instinct is to kind of pull out the big
guns you know be like what what deep
learning can i throw at this what super
fancy model can solve my problems
um
with magic you know but
uh
the main advantage that deep learning
brings in nlp is that it allows words to
be understood in their greater context
right if you have like a paragraph of
text or even a sentence but in this case
we are looking at very short strings of
text maybe three or four words uh
excluding stop words and
even you know people will write just a
list of of a list of words or is kind of
shorthand so there wasn't a lot to be
gained from
contextualizing the words that we were
looking at so deep learning really
wasn't the solution
um and i mentioned earlier you know we
had
we basically were
swinging the model from side to side
like we would get some success in some
parts with one model some success in
another in another and other parts of
the classifications that we needed with
another model
um
so we really couldn't you know neither
of the things that we were trying were
really solving our problem and so what
we ended up doing was using both and so
we had the best of both worlds
so we moved to an ensemble model which
was hybrid it used both rules-based
classification and machine learning
classification
um
[Music]
so i'll take you through it we had the
input text we ran it through the spell
check just like before
um and then we had we ran the text
through a set of rules and these rules
encompassed uh covered a lot of the
cases where for example with trauma um
we needed
the
model to focus on particular terms
weight particular terms more than others
and just waiting the simple training set
was not uh was causing errors in the
opposite direction it was over
correcting
so for example for the bullet wound um
we had a dictionary of terms that
describe
uh
violent traumatic injuries it was a
really
pleasant dictionary to compile um and if
any of those gruesome words is found in
the text that we're trying to classify
then
the rule about
wounds and trauma catches that text and
sends it straight to classification as
wound slash trauma it doesn't
it just bypasses the machine learning
models completely
so the last rule that we send it through
if none of the other rules caught that
text
is to determine if there's any
indication that the text we're looking
at
involves cancer in any way because the
client had emphasized that even if
multiple conditions were
present
if cancer was one of them you know
cancer will have a lot of like secondary
conditions that come from it but the
cancer is the root so they wanted cancer
to be prioritized um and so we made
a cancer model if that the text would be
sent to if it had
any indication that cancer was present
and a non-cancer model for all the
others and those are mutually exclusive
um
universes of classification i guess
so these
machine learning models work basically
the same way as the original model does
they're just streamlined in their
classification tasks so each of these
sub-models has a smaller set we have
three sub-models and each sub-model has
a smaller set of classification tasks
which allows them to
really
focus on i don't know i'm speaking about
the models like their people but you
know we kind of feel like they are um so
it allows them to focus on their more
narrow classification task and the
results are less diluted by the sheer
number of categories that they're trying
to sort things into
so
back to these examples if we see it in
practice for the first two it didn't
really change much we had
diabetes and carpal tunnel they aren't
picked up by any of the rules and
neither of them have anything to do with
cancer so they're just classified by the
non-cancer model
um
pancreatic cancer of course cancer is an
indication that cancer is involved so it
gets sent to the oncology model
um which now has a much easier task of
just it only has
oncology classifications to output so
i think there were 13 different oncology
based classifications and they you know
once we know that it's cancer it's
really easy for the model to understand
that the pain you know pancreatic means
digestive system and so it doesn't
um
it doesn't dilute the probability of
that specific
uh
classification by having the other
digestive system category there um
watering down that probability so on the
other side of the same coin we have
pancreatitis is in the non-cancer model
and that non-cancer model can classify
it as digestive system
in a really confident way you know with
a really high confidence without having
that confidence watered down by the
presence of an
another digestive system classification
and finally our favorite
bullet wound classification bullet wound
is obviously in that gruesome dictionary
of wounds and trauma terms
um and so that was caught by the world's
base classification and sent directly to
that classification without needing to
involve the machine learning models
so this solution resulted in a much more
stable model it was much more accurate
much more consistently and it really
fell in line with exactly what the
client wanted um you know when they
wanted certain things to be weighted we
were able to accommodate that
um without sacrificing sort of accuracy
in other places
so it also allowed us to overcome the
gaps that we were facing in the training
data instead of having to follow up with
the client that we really need this data
we can't we can't finish the model until
we have it we were able to say um
we were able to just devise a set of
rules by having a simple conversation
with a subject matter expert so that was
a lot less burden on the client it
worked for us everybody went home happy
and then um this solution also allowed
us to have that clear distinction
between these kind of tricky cases to
know exactly where we needed to
weight the
which
those particular terms that were more
important than the others
and finally it doesn't it wasn't
strictly part of the ensemble model but
we did while we were adding rules into
the mix we did
add some new tricks like uh we added a
rules-based flag
to identify particularly severe disease
for prioritization in the system
so
basically the moral of the story is you
can have it all um you can't if two
models are working you know one on one
half of what you need and the other on
the other half of what you need um
hybrid models and ensemble models are
going to be a really great way to
combine them and um
kind of
up you know get the best of both worlds
for optimal uh
optimal results
and
that is the end of my presentation thank
you guys so much